they can finally kill sukuna the power
of the sorcerers is getting stronger by
the minute and even sukuna is impressed
and now with the Executioner sword at
their disposal maybe this is finally it
for
sukuna I'm kidding of course gay is
about to pull another reverse Uno on us
you know it's coming and this will
change everything so let's break it down
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my jjk content leave a quick like
and comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if if you want to help
this channel attain special grade status
by hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are very close finally this video will
of course contain jjk manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter gave us
the intense fight between hakari and Ur
and then we got the insane trial of
sukuna followed by a deadly twist and
the arrival of multiple jutu Sorcerers
to the main Battlefield now as far as
I'm aware ur's gender is still
technically listed as unknown but if the
official viz translation can be believed
then in chapter 245 hakari seems to have
confirmed that Ur is a girl anyway the
Big trial was way shorter than anyone
expected after establishing that judg
man is able to differentiate between two
different Souls even if they reside in
the same body higuma argues that sukuna
is the one responsible for the Shibuya
Massacre not Yuji because sukuna had
hijacked yuji's body during that event
but sukuna says that he doesn't care
about the court proceedings and he
practically admits his guilt judg man
isn't playing around and immediately
finds sukuna guilty and sentences him to
both confiscation and the death penalty
as the sentence is carried out higuma
explains that he believes that sukuna
lost the ability to use the 10 Shadows
technique during his fight with Gojo so
that means that the sentence of
confiscation must be applied to his
innate technique meaning that suuna
should not be capable of using his
deadly slashing attacks any longer this
is good news for higuma because the
other sentence death penalty means that
he will now get to use the legendary
executioner sword against sukuna and we
know for a fact that this sword does
have the power to kill even the king of
curses himself so higuma and the other
sorcerers are thinking okay sukuna is
probably worn out from his fight with
Gojo he can't use 10 Shadows anymore he
can't use his own inate techniqu M level
and Shrine anymore and higuma has a
sword that can kill anyone hey they
might actually stand up chance here and
so in that moment kusakabe Ino and choso
all rush to the battlefield to help hiur
man Yuji take sukuna down but sadly
their hopefulness doesn't last very long
as we soon find out when the target of
judgment's confiscation possesses a
cursed object the power of that object
is confiscated instead of the target's
own innate technique so this means that
super suuna still has his slashing
powers and he launches them at higuma
immediately he instantly Cuts higuma
body in dozens of places and he would
likely have died if kusakabe hadn't
stepped in to take some of the hits with
his own body and then choso Andino
joined the fry as well and then all hell
breaks loose man gig really likes to
tease us that someone might finally have
a solution against sukuna only to laugh
right in our face if we fall for it even
for a second stick around until the end
of the video because I will explain why
I think gay is about to do the same
thing to us again okay so huruma is
almost completely caught off guard by
The Twist that sukuna still has his
innate technique and part of that is due
to higuma lack of proper battle
experience this dude was just a lawyer
and he only became a sorcerer like less
than 2 months ago thankfully kusaka is
able to use new Shadow style simple
domain to decrease the amount of damage
that sukuna slashing attacks are doing
which allows the sorcerers to at least
survive for now sukunai is using
dismantle but but he is not using the
kind of overpowered slash that can cut
space itself the attack he used to
allegedly kill Gojo as you guys know
because I mention it in every video I
still think that Gojo can beat the being
dead allegations but we'll see cop
Springs Eternal one other thing that
kusak notices is that sukuna is not
using that fire innate technique that he
had used back in Shibuya the same
technique he used to destroy the special
great curse Joo kusaka assumes that
sukuna isn't using that technique
because he can't use it right now for
whatever reason and if sukuna really
can't use the technique then that is
really good news for the sorcerers
because those blazing fire attacks that
he used on Joo were absolutely
incredible higuma then explains to
kusakabe that even though they got the
sentences they were hoping for sukuna
still got to keep his cursed technique
because the confiscation was applied to
suk's Cursed object instead of his
innate technique however kusaka is still
thinks that they have a chance because
they have the Executioner sword and that
sword is the quickest and easiest
solution to end this fight kusaka viles
to protect higuma and the sword at all
costs even if it costs him his life
kusakabe surprises even himself with how
committed he is to winning the fight but
I mean he has a point if sukuna wins and
gains the ability to essentially control
the world unimpeded the result would be
an absolute disaster for all of humanity
even if kusakabe survived the fight he
would be absolutely screwed afterwards
so he might as well give it his all
right here and now sukuna is impressed
with kusakabe ability to defend against
his slashes but of course sukuna is just
getting started and he still has plenty
of tricks up his sleeve thankfully choso
shows up to back up the other sorcerers
and he tries to use his piercing blood
attack against the king of curses but
sukuna quickly appears in front of choso
and runs his entire hand through Choo's
body clearly delivering a severe injury
this would absolutely be a fatal injury
in the real world but this is a battle
shown in and choso is not a normal human
so he probably could survive this I mean
JJ JK isn't shy to kill off significant
Side characters so it's possible that
choso could die but just personally I
don't think he's going to go out like
this I could be wrong but that's my
hunch Eno shows up as well and sukai is
kind of impressed with how much stronger
all of these guys have gotten and how
powerful their attacks are Eno's cursed
weapon now seems to contain nanami's
curse technique within it and he
delivers a hit to sukuna that ends up
being a lot harder than sukuna had
expected which again kind of impresses
sukuna that said though sukuna is still
dominating this fight and all the other
sorcerers Yuji included are basically
just fighting desperately to stay alive
and to keep their comrades alive even
though sukuna is outnumbered by all
these Sorcerers they are the ones
desperately trying to dodge and protect
themselves and each other from sua's
absolutely monstrous attacks the
priority here is to protect higuma and
the Executioner Sword without that sword
the sorcerers really don't stand the
chance so they have to keep it out of
the villain's hands no matter what as
sukuna attempts to chase down and catch
huruma Yuji runs after him desperately
trying to catch up to him and prevent
him from killing higuma Yuji realizes
that sukuna is just insanely fast and
even trying to keep up with him is
practically impossible then we see a
quick flashback to when the sorcerers
were discussing their battle plan
against sukuna before the beginning of
the battle even then they knew that the
Executioner sword would be the best way
to defeat sukuna because not only is it
one of the only things capable of
actually killing him but it is also able
to distinguish between different Souls
and so if sukuna is cut down by the
Executioner sword only he would die and
megumi would not be harmed that's
because only sukuna was declared guilty
and so the punishment only applies to
him megumi didn't do anything wrong so
the sword wouldn't harm him even if it
destroyed sukuna this is obviously super
important for the sorcerers because they
want to save megumi and kill sukuna at
the same time they don't want to kill
megumi in order to get rid of sukuna
during the flashback it is established
that higuma is willing to put his life
on the line in the battle against sukuna
and despite not being a fighter again
he's a lawyer he is prepared to die for
the cause of Justice it's like he feels
guilty that he strayed away from the
path of Law and Order and just kind of
took the law into his own hands and he
seems to feel like dying while defeating
sukuna would help him atone for that at
least to some extent this is something
that Yugi can definitely relate to
because he still feels guilty about all
the horrible crimes that sukuna
committed while he was possessed
possessing his own body back in the
present higuma manages to use domain
amplification to neutralize sukuna
technique and survive I guess higuma
just learned how to use it on the fly
right now so that is just incredible
sukura knows that higuma awakened as a
sorcerer less than two months ago and so
to the king of curses this is extremely
impressive higuma has had immense growth
in such a short period of time in that
moment the Executioner sword begins to
shine again and then it's Aura seems to
engulf higuma entire body as the chapter
implies that full power higuma with the
Executioner sword could rival the power
of even Satur Gojo himself we are led to
believe yet again that maybe just maybe
there is some chance that the sorcerers
can actually defeat sukuna I mean they
have the Executioner sword right and
even sukuna is impressed so maybe this
could really be his end of course not
this is definitely just another tease by
G in the very next after we might see
sukuna regaining the initiative and
straight up killing an important
character like it was nothing it's
happened before so never discount the
absolute Menace that is Ren sukuna
personally I'm definitely impressed by
higuma and I do think that he has an
important role to play in this fight but
like I said in my last jjk video I just
don't see higuma being the one to
actually take sukuna down with the
Executioner sword if sukuna is meant to
be defeated by this sword then the
person who will end up wielding it will
likely end up being a much more
important character someone like Utah or
even Yuji higuma will play his part and
it's an important part and he was the
one who brought the Executioner sword
into the equation but from a writing
perspective I think that in the end a
character like higuma will have to take
a backseat to the big boys like Yuji and
UTA what do you guys think will someone
else like Yuji or UTA end up wielding
the Executioner sword against sukuna
huruma is definitely being glazed by the
narrator right now but will he manage to
become a major character or will he just
become another one of sua's victims
finally why haven't you liked and
subscribed yet it is totally free and it
helps me out a lot oh and if you did
like And subscribe already congrats now
you get to feel smug because what I said
didn't apply to you if you're looking
for another epic jjk video to watch next
check out my video about sukuna secret
brother link on screen and in the
description